[Musik]
diese geschichte beginnt an einem
nasskalten winter morgen in zürich
kloten und spielt zwischen himmel und
erde und zwischen zwei welten der
schweiz und der karibik
sie handelt von der suche nach der
heimat sei es hier oder dort
sie handelt von samuel feierabend der in
altdorf lebt und zurück fliegt ins land
seiner mutter in die dominikanische
republik
samuel hat große pläne samuel will
heiraten
grübeln in der karibik wartet seine
braut affin kurz vor weihnachten soll
die hochzeit sein
[Musik]
samuels reise führt ins hinterland zur
dominikanischen republik hinauf in die
berge dorthin muss ich kaum ein tourist
verirrt hier lebte samuel bis zu seinem
fünfzehnten autos ja
[Musik]
es ist eine reise in die vergangenheit
und in die zukunft zugleich denn dort wo
er aufgewachsen ist wartet jetzt seine
praktische
und das ist sie da er 17 jahre alt
verliebt und verlobt ein schweizerisch
karibisches bahn auf der zielgeraden in
die fast ein jahr haben sie sich nicht
gesehen
[Musik]
und was ist er denn so für ein typ will
ich wissen so sagt er ist schön und
sympathisch
[Musik]
si
fantastisch
sehr romantisch
und
sehr gute menschen
[Musik]
bald nach der ankunft gehen die beiden
erst in friedhof dort liegt samuels
vater begraben karl feyerabend
dieser war anfangs der 80er jahre
hierher ausgewandert und hatte mit
seiner frau marina vier söhne
[Musik]
[Applaus]
karl feierabend aus der schweiz starb am
21 februar 2007 mit 62 jahren an einem
herzinfarkt branche lieber in der
dominikanischen republik
[Musik]
in einem einfachen häuschen aufgebahrt
war sein tod wie sein leben bescheiden
leise ganz unauffällig verabschiedete er
sich aus dieser welt als wollte er auch
im tod kein weiteres aufheben machen
[Musik]
und so beginnt seine geschichte in den
80er jahren zog es einige schweizer
auswanderer hierher ins café gebiet der
karibikinsel
sie zogen in ein kleines kaff namens
runkeeper in eine landschaft die
manchmal ein bisschen an die schweizerin
dort traf ich vor genau 25 jahren karl
feyerabend zum ersten mal
carlos heiße hier früher kali kompass
rotkohl feierabend der in seinem ersten
leben für alle der 4a become a
17 jahre lang waren schnapsbrenner mit
eigener bringen light geben gesehen aber
löwen
[Musik]
dann
1982 begann sein zweites leben charakter
haben gut in einem container und
verschickte ihn hierher in die tropen
pharma wollte er werden groß fahren
dass er hier nur gerade ein paar gänse
statt einer rinderherde vor sich her
treiben würde hatte sich damals zu hause
in rotkreuz nicht träumen lassen 17
jahre lang hatte er gespart über 200000
franken immerhin als startkapital in der
frage
sondern
nicht über
den
weg
und
so hatte es begonnen kari schloss sich
einer gruppe land interessenten an und
flog auf die karibikinsel auf
vermittlung der schweizerisch
dominikanischen markfort roubini
besichtigte kari einige farben und
entschloss sich schließlich zusammen mit
fischer hans aus dem toggenburg zum kauf
einer farm von 93 hektaren 66 davon
gehörten carey in einem achteckigen
besuchsprogramm waren sie durchs land
geschleust worden für nur 50 rappen pro
tag könne man hier taglöhner anstellen
wurde versprochen und bereits am 8 tage
hieß es vertragsabschlüsse in unseren
büros nachmittags frei die groupie nie
versprach bei der bewirtschaftung
behilflich zu sein und schloss mit kari
einen vertrag ab die makler kauften
dringen und saatgut versprachen die
ernte zu verkaufen und rechneten die
schönen gewinne aus die dazu machen sein
die bohnen wuchsen zwar durchaus den
gewinnen wurde nichts kg war der falsche
berechnungen hereingefallen sind sie
danach nicht gläubig sie
ja auch
hineinreichen
[Musik]
nach anderthalb jahren war er pleite
khalifa los ein ganzes land für das er
über 200000 franken hingeblättert hatten
ein lebenstraum in trümmern
zwölf jahre später machte ich mich
nochmals auf die suche nach kali denn
die frage stellte sich warum kehrt einer
wie er pleite wer war nicht einfach in
die schweiz zurück unter das dach des
sozialstaates es war nicht schwierig ihn
wiederzufinden
orangerie bei dem kleinen dorf im café
gebiet wo er genau liegt sieht man von
weitem
ich
bin ja komitee erscheinen schreiben
eigentlich noch geschwitzt naja
trotz pleite und pech ist calida
geblieben und auf anhieb käme keiner auf
die idee dass es sich hier um einen
ausländer handelt karli lebt wie ein
einheimischer casino eine mit schweizer
fahne allerdings
kari hat sich mit ein paar tausend
franken die ihm nach seiner pleite von
damals übrig geblieben waren drei hektar
und land in der gleichen gegend gekauft
ihr lebt er seit elf jahren aus
kleinbauer und irgendwie wundert er sich
noch heute darüber wie er hierher
geraten ist
geschmeidig eine dem abriss wo die
dominikanische republik ich
hab ich keine von santo domingo
in der dominikanischen
republik
[Musik]
und am abend räumten sie von santo
domingo
[Musik]
obwohl kali komplett pleite war wieder
hier
einfach zurück die schweiz
menü mit kreide
schneefalls im container wird oder
braucht
die hand
und
hatte die messe
natürlich gibt es noch einen grund er
heißt marina mit ihr lebt caritas in der
schweiz ein eiserner junggeselle war
seit zwölf jahren zusammen in einem
bescheidenen häuschen am rande eines
kleinen grundstücks
im laufe der jahre sind noch viele
gründe mehr dazu gekommen um hier zu
bleiben
fred zepp unterton die schweizer buben
arm aber glücklich so viel gotthelf gibt
es nur noch hinter karin
[Musik]
großes glück in einer bescheidenen hütte
alles selber gebaut und kali zwei zimmer
und eine küche
[Musik]
im schlafzimmer wachen nebst hiesigen
heiligen auch schweizer ikonen über die
hälfe des karibischen
sich den platz
auf drei hektar diese waren ist eine
veritable plantage entstanden mit zwölf
sorten bananen orangen mandarinen
passionsfrucht kiwis und kaffee
[Musik]
der
dreisprachig
[Musik]
ja gut
kaffee ist ein unsicheres geschäft kari
lebt mehr schlecht als recht von seinem
kleinen anwesen am café verdiente er
wenn es hochkommt 1000 bis 2000 franken
im jahr überlebt hat kann weil es eine
schweiß anlage aus der schweiz
mitgebracht hatte er fliegt alles was
ihm die nachbarn bringen so kommt er auf
ein monatseinkommen von umgerechnet
250 bis 300 franken
er ist so ein fleißiger mensch und er
kümmert sich um die kinder dann ist
immer hier er ist sehr häuslich herget
niehaus er trinkt nicht nur junge nicht
auf der straße herum ein guter mann
nur jährlich dieser riesige barth in der
schneidet ihn ja
nein dieser bank das gefällt mir nicht
immer
einfach zu viele haare im gesicht
und
betrogen
erfahren
als er von einem verlorenen verloren
total unglücklich nicht los leider fällt
die schweiz beteiligt sich an der
dritten konferenz
konvention den nächsten wochen
so kam es dass aus dem innerschweizer
schnapsbrennen ein casino geworden ist
der einzige allerdings der radio schweiz
international hörte so lange ist dieses
noch gar
[Musik]
die noch
vier jahre später
vier abi carius leben hat sich äußerlich
nicht groß verändert doch vieles läuft
nicht so wie er es sich erträumt hatte
geld wird immer mehr zur mangelware
versteckte und der bananen staaten hat
carlos eine improvisierte
schnapsbrennerei aufgebaut die geplante
verschiedene sorten exotischer schnäpse
schwarz natürlich
die schnäpse haben 62 prozent alkohol
und schmecken am besten nachts kafi
schnaps mit tropen und
dass ich
aus dem waschkessel ist eine
funktionstüchtige busch destillerie
geworden
charis kinder gehen in rancho reaper ins
gymnasium dieses werden sie nach zwölf
schuljahren beendet haben und dann
werden sie das gleiche problem haben wie
alle hier was tun die arbeitslosigkeit
beträgt mehr als 50 prozent und jeder
der hier noch bei trost ist sagt sich
nichts wie weg in ein anderes land in
die usa nach spanien oder eben in die
schweiz und so kam es denn das am
vierten august 2005 palette feierabend
in der schweiz eintraf erwartet von
seiner tante lisbeth und ihrem land
deutsch kann kalte fast gar nicht mit
seinem vater hat er niemals spanisch
geredet erste verständigung versuche
so macht der sohn des kali denn
umgekehrt geblieben sein vater er will
hier arbeiten geld verdienen dass er
seinem vater in die karibik schicken
kann und er will in der schweiz das
werden was bisher nur sein pass
verspricht ein richtiger schweizer
schlafen
den stühlen draußen verlegt
ein weiteres jahr ist ins land gegangen
er lebt jetzt in früheren im herz der in
schweiz sozusagen
er lebt bei seiner tante lisbeth der
schwester seines vaters und ihrem mann
sap und man hat ihn hier offensichtlich
gern
[Musik]
gekauft
so sitzt
ruhig
bist du bist
mach mal
ist es ein schwerer zu finden
alles
nichts oder
wenig ist ja vielleicht nicht aber
finde ich
das gar nicht geredet aber
ich meine es gefällt dir
gefällt mir genug was gefragt ist
einmalig in der schweiz
also
wenig riechende frauen
ja
kennst du
nicht ein wenig
weil er ein bisschen einsam ist hat er
sich 24 einige freunde angeschafft
minuten handlung ich kann nicht 100
haare haushalt auf eine rate also also
wollte ich ein affe alles muss in afrika
kaufen
na ja heute schon eine rate und gefällt
mir
dass das viele geld das er verdienen
möchte in der schweiz nicht auf der
straße liegt musste gallito schnell
lernen jetzt arbeitet er für 20 franken
in der stunde in der fenster fabrik
bündner in erstfeld wo man grundsätzlich
des lobes voll ist über ihn er macht
hier die erfahrungen eines ganz
gewöhnlichen immigranten einfache arbeit
statt plötzlichen reichtums und er hat
ein dilemma er ist zwar ein schweizer
mit pass aber irgendwie halten ihn für
irgendetwas anderes
so scheinen die schweizer im
hirschen kommt das
stück
ist
also ich habe noch ganz am
oberrhein ich sage das sehr positive
worte gemacht
dann bricht begrüßen es auch durchzieht
und mit miranda mal zieht also
wie ist verschaffen eine vertraute ist
auch wie stockend es klarheit karriere
machte das merkt man sich und dadurch
dass ich jetzt besser da wirtschaftlich
ist das hier anders als in der karibik
nicht an andere was ist
alles ganz perfekt machen
können nichts
milito ist in einer schweiz geraten von
der keine ahnung hatte eine moderne
durch organisierte gesellschaft weit und
breit kein pferdefuhrwerk
was ist dein größter wunsch als ein
guter wein gute laune eine schöne haus
wo ich kann meine familie haben auch an
der
eine frau in dem auch viele kollegen ein
wesentlicher schritt in der
verschweißung des schweizers carlito ist
natürlich die sprache
einmal pro woche besuchte den
deutschunterricht in autor also
hierherkam sprache wie gesagt noch kein
wort und wenn das gegenüber stimmt man
sieht es gleich lernt es sich leichter
ich bin
verheiratet er sich leicht für mich
die mythen der schweiz könnte bereits
allerdings in einer karibik version
was hast du für
eine starke mann
ohne angst
hat jemand getötet ein jesuit war so
wild
[Musik]
ja wie ich sagen dass
wollte ja alles
leute
muss gerät seine
eigene kappe oder etwas verhalten
[Musik]
nach anderthalb jahren erstmals wieder
zurück in der dominikanischen republik
zusammen mit seiner tante lisbeth und
ihrem mann selbst zu besuch beim vater
und bei den brüdern
hier ist es wie eh und je von morgens
früh bis abends spät unterwegs auf
seinem kleinen hof drei hektaren
plantage einkauf eine co2 kehrte
carlito ist für seine brüder so etwas
wie ein vorbild er hat sich einen
computer angeschafft und zeigte ihnen
bilder aus der fernen heimat schweiz er
ist ihr wegbereiter in die bessere
zukunft
auch sami freddy und pepe träume nur
davon dorthin zu ziehen wo milch und
honig fließt also in die schweiz lieber
heute als morgen
harry macht mit seinen buben den ganzen
haushalt denn seine ehefrau marina ist
wieder einmal weg dieses mal ist in
spanien wo sie als putzfrau arbeitet und
das einkommen der familie aufzubessern
eine zeit lang war sie in miami denn wir
wollen es nicht verschweigen auch das
eheglück der feierabend ist nicht mehr
so wie einst im mai
mit dem selbst gebackenem brot bananen
schnaps und käse aus der schweiz fühlt
man sich ein bisschen wie vor bis heute
eine idylle auf zeit die frau ist
auswärts und auch die kinder man so bald
wie möglich
sonst hatte cali bei solchen
gelegenheiten gerne das lied auf meiner
ranch bin ich könig gesungen doch heute
stand in der sinn nach etwas traurigen
[Musik]
version
9.1 endlich weg wie sie bei weniger
kreis und komitee vor thema als
tiefstapler der petrus
damaseb
bestimmt und ein
am späteren abend ging es ganz und gar
nicht mehr gut er musste in das fast
drei stunden entfernte spital gebracht
werden es wurde immer schlechter auf den
holprigen straßen er konnte kaum mehr
atmen alles tat ihm weh ein wiedersehen
im lied
alles deutet darauf hin dass kali einen
kleineren herzinfarkt gehabt hatte
foto pi
mögliche taktik
[Musik]
niemand hätte es gedacht nach einem tag
im spital hatte kari abends um halb elf
einen zweiten herzinfarkt der sofort
tödlich war
[Musik]
kommts komischer vorn
doch die stark wohin die fahrt
mit dem gare hängt
ein großer tour
das
closing
herbst ehrlich sympathisch passiert auch
glück sieht
peter buck zeit
genug sich auf meiner ranch bin ich
trainer
das land sei und wohin gesichert nur
verdammt denn
hacker ausgeholt das enge tal apa
aus der traum
[Musik]
wales ja wie war das jetzt ohne den
vater schwer
ist
wesentlich schwieriger
wird uns
geforderte
gemacht diese nacht war nicht
für uns das war ganz komisch gelaufen
wenn wir
nicht mehr
da kann ich mich
wie war dein vater
ich warte eine gute fahrt
sie erlebt mit den kindern
er hat sich hinzugesellt
tapfer versuchen die vier buben so etwas
wie normalität herzustellen
fred i arbeitet weiterhin die
schlosserei
habe dies von seinem vater so gelernt du
machen es genau wie diesen sagte mir
so sind sie alleine gelassen der vater
gestorben und die mutter weit weg
in einem vorort von barcelona treffe ich
marina wieder die witwe von kari
arbeitet viel aus hausangestellte weil
sie kein flugticket und kein geld hatte
konnte sie auch nicht zurück fliegen aus
dem mann stahl
wie war das als sie hörte dass er
gestorben ist
es war sehr hart ein harter schlag
ich hätte nie so etwas gedacht ich
dachte wenn ich dorthin zurückkehre
werde ich ihn antreffen wie immer
in saarlouis
nein nie hätte ich gedacht dass mich ein
solches schicksal trifft
warum arbeitest du eigentlich hier in
spanien
ich wollte hier arbeiten um kari zu
helfen damit er nicht so viel arbeiten
muss er war schon älter und ich wollte
dass er was hat und weil ich jünger bin
dachte ich ich könnte mir zum einkommen
beitragen
aber so ist das leben dort wo er jetzt
ist man dort kommt keine zurück wie ist
denn deine zukunft
ich weiß es nicht aber wenn ich arbeite
dann tue ich das um meine kinder
voranzubringen damit ihnen nie etwas
fehlen wird und
muss man dazu im ausland
ja schon die in santo domingo gibt es
nichts dort muss man entweder
beziehungen haben oder ein politiker
sein aber das gefällt mir nicht da
gehöre ich nicht dazu
werden alle deine kinder später in der
schweiz leben
[Musik]
das kann durchaus sein aber das stück
land das karree gehört wird immer unser
land als andenken ankara ein andenken
für immer
wie sehen sie denn deine kinder sie sind
so wunderbar sie sind mit mir wunderbar
und sie waren wunderbar mit ihrem vater
über seinen tod hinaus hat calli für die
seiten gesorgt weil sein bruder in der
schweiz immer brav die ahv einbezahlt
hatte wird marina eine schweizerische
witwenrente bekommen und die kinder eine
waisenrente solange sie in ausbildung
sind
[Musik]
so endete das leben der schnapsbrenner
skull feierabend in der gleichen art wie
alles leben irgendwann endet und es
setzt sich gleichzeitig ford durch die
kinder und kindeskinder nämlich die noch
lange erzählen werden von cali der aus
dem fernen im lande ausgerechnet hierher
kam wo doch alle anderen nichts wie weg
wollen
[Musik]
im fluss des lebens werden nun die söhne
an seine stelle treten ihr eigenes leben
füllen ihre eigenen kinder haben in
denen irgendwie auch der autor noch
weiterleben wird
im fall der feierabend sieht das nächste
kapitel in dieser unendlichen geschichte
so aus dass am 20 april 2007 der jüngste
der söhne der 15-jährige sami in
zürich-kloten ankommt
[Musik]
seine tante lisbeth deren eigene kinder
ausgeflogen sind wird sich um ihn
kümmern
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sind
ein weiteres jahr ist ins land gegangen
und sie lebt nun auch in früheren bei
seiner tante lisbeth und ihrem mann sepp
doch sehr bald nachdem er hier ankam
stellte sich heraus dass alles bei ihm
ziemlich langsam ging kurz gesagt er
kann sich fast nichts merken
schulisch waren nie weit gekommen in
sechs jahren hat er zwei mal die klasse
wiederholen müssen
ist es schwierig für dich gold zu lernen
da ist ja
was ist schwieriger wenig lesen
es ist schwierig für mich ja
und wie geht s die sonst in der schweiz
naja gut
was gefällt dir
gut
wusstest du dass deine ganze familie ist
besser alle familien ist
wirst du
ja
seine mutter sei gut sagte quinn fehle
was sie koche früher sei sie immer da
gewesen wenn er nach hause gekommen sei
auto und flugzeug
ja das ist ein traum
des roten schlosses
und meine mutter kommt in den
sorten
ist versprochen
und wenn ein
nebelmeer hat und das war
aber wieso der jüngst wie sozusagen
ihren wir sind eine dynamische
duo mit dem kopf und ein schulisches
hauptrolle der schweiz sich möglichst
unter ihnen auch ein ich früher tätig
gestiegen und alle drücken auch
behinderung
haben wir das merkt man
es praktisch noch vom leder ist typisch
deutsch sprach das leichtgewicht es auch
in spanisch nicht
die gesamte zeit ist es somit zum lernen
und
da hat er zeit aber hat das grab
beobachteten
realisieren betongold aber kind
und auch das im galopp seit und der
tagseite das signal dass sie genau mit
trikots und bildung skeet und zig
bewusstlos
und denn
siebdrucke und heckenschützen und das
vergnügen ist und daher mit waffen der
sieger wieder
richtig dass eine effektive
körperlich hat sie das eben
oder durch süßstoff man muss das einfach
lernschwierigkeiten
und
fröhlichen überhaupt er kommt mit gordon
back und dann schaffe ich gut
morgens um 5 uhr in erstfeld wie hat sie
mir eine stelle gefunden als hilfskraft
beim bäcker roessing noch nie sei er zu
spät gekommen lobt man ihn
für sie ist das fast schon so etwas wie
ein traumberuf auch zu hause hat er viel
gebacken zusammen mit seinem vater
außer meeresforschung ausstrahlt mir
sofort gefesselt und ich merke aber auch
studierende und was für mich am vortag
alle personen und
lebensfreude mit buchstaben und das
niveau der schub psychologisch abgeklärt
und die resultate waren derart dass man
ihn in eine sonderschule einweisen
wollte
doch er selber sowie tante und onkel
waren dagegen
komplett
anderes
spiel mal was leben
gar nicht
braucht einfach mehr
braucht
zwei mal pro woche geht sie in die
deutschstunde im schulhaus vom früheren
board wartet frau valsecchi auf ihn die
im einzel stunden gibt
demnach darf mit
ja nein nein ich denke das ist gerade
nein der
ist krank
das
junge der junge dessen
stopp betastet das vergessen der junge
gesunken ist gesunken ist nach seinem
stopp jetzt probieren wir einen satz zu
sagen jetzt ist nur das auto stieß die
frau
ist
naja lassen das metall ist
schlecht
probiert es nochmals
recht
frech brecht ist dann ist es nicht gut
fröhlich fröhlich
also ich glaube diese chance sehe ich
hier im moment sich mit profis lernen
so viel machen
begannen mit drei toten hat für afrika
hat ja nicht anders kann und das ist ja
immer so wenn man
es so schnell vergessen und das freue
ihn gefragt nach studien zu
nein null spielen und auf das
was man oft
hat
die 2
wo dann am 21 januar 2008 war es endlich
soweit sami und kalli torwarten zusammen
mit fokus auf die mutter auf marina
smi geht diese lange zeit der einsamkeit
zu ende
[Musik]
mit marina kommt kredit der dritte der
söhne von kari jetzt ist nur noch pepe
in der karibik doch auch er wird bald
hier sein das liegt wie wir nun gemerkt
haben sozusagen in der logik dieser
geschichte
wie geht es dir marina ich bin so
glücklich sagt sie jetzt habe ich schon
mal ein trainieren
[Musik]
das tut meine mutter kommt ja
willst du wirklich gut
marina ist fest entschlossen hier in der
schweiz ein neues leben zu beginnen
in vita schwanden im schächental dort wo
im winter drei monate lang die sonne
scheint hat rallye tor für die ganze
familie eine wohnung gemietet eine
günstige weit ab vom schuss
[Musik]
fünfeinhalb zimmer noch etwas
provisorisch eingerichtet aber immerhin
ein neues zuhause für die familie
wir schauen wir wenig fernsehen sagt
marina obwohl sie die tagesschau noch
nicht wirklich versteht
maria ist stolz und zeigt mir das
ziemlich von carlito dass sie
ausgesprochen romantisch findet
[Musik]
nein einen solchen kühlschrank hatte
marina die leidenschaftliche köchin noch
nie
die einrichtung bringt die familie an
den rahmen den finanziellen kräfte
ihre einkünfte aus witten rente und
carlitos lohn liegen um die 4000 franken
pro monat aber es ist teuer in der
schweiz und die jungen sind den
elektronischen verführungen ziemlich
ausgeliefert mit schweizer franken zu
rechnen das müssen sie erst noch lernen
suchst du eigentlich arbeit hier ja ich
möchte irgendetwas arbeiten
ich frage nicht was mir gefällt ich
suche irgendetwas ich möchte nicht reich
werden oder so etwas ich möchte noch
etwas zum leben haben und ich möchte
alles was möglich ist für mich und auch
noch etwas mehr damit ich für die
anderen meiner familie sorgen kann
was kannst du nicht gut
also ich kann ein wenig kochen
irgendetwas
ich möchte keine sekretärin sein aber
sogar das würde ich versuchen wenn es
sein müsste wichtig ist einfach etwas zu
tun und das mit liebe nicht mehr
hier ist freddys zimmer und hier haben
wir alle trophäen von kari seine
medaillen seine kristalle und so weiter
[Musik]
und hier ist noch seine uhr die läuft
immer noch
[Musik]
kali ist in der wohnung omnipräsent
die bilder an der wand machen die
familiengeschichte zu legende doch wir
wissen gab es in dieser ehe nicht nur
eitel sonnenschein wie
es denn so gewesen sei mit
carina wissen
auf der einen seite was gut und auf der
anderen ein
eines muss ich sagen er war fleißig und
er war gut zu den kindern da fehlte
nichts aber es fehlte etwas anderes mehr
fehlte etwas ich kam zu kurz ich bin
doch das wichtigste aber lassen wir das
vor der kamera
aber die zu wenig zärtlichkeit aber
sicher war
ja wie der schnee da draußen so kalt
aber lassen wir das
und du weißt ja wenn in einem haushalt
ein feuer brennt und du kein holzen
abschießt damals du was passiert ja so
war das
feuer
ja klar aber wie gesagt er war ein guter
vater das können sie dir bestätigen
könnte es sein dass so nochmals heirat
ist
ja sicher ich glaube schon wenn das
leben mir jemanden wunderbares vorbei
schickt nur da
aber wenn einer kommt der die mühle
nicht lohnt dann lasse ich es lieber
bleiben
lieber nichts als einen der immer läuft
streitet auch oder große reden führt
so einen solchen nein danke
in altdorf im hotel höflich hat marina
dank der guten beziehungen ihre
schweizer verwandten eine stelle als
putzfrau gefunden
ihr schweizer pass und ein soziales
netzwerk machen das schicksal der
feierabends im vergleich zu anderen
immigranten natürlich ziemlich leicht
abgesehen von der sprache
wie redest du eigentlich mit den leuten
mit händen und füßen sagt marina wie die
stummen reden wir hier oder wie die
kinder
im berufsbildungszentrum instanz besucht
carlito eine ausländer klasse die auf
die lehre vorbereiten soll hier lernt
der frauen deutsch und hier wollte ich
khalid an einem donnerstagmorgen treffen
doch weit und breit keine spur nur eine
ausrede per sms es tut mir leid dass ich
nicht in die schule kommen kann wir sind
gestern abend erst um 21 15 nach hause
gekommen und heute habe ich keinen bus
was bedeutet das letzte chance weißt ja
ich denke dass ich für ihn ganz
schwierig das geht für ihn eine ganz
schwierige situation
also das kommt natürlich offen eine
arbeit gehabt
aber ich denke
dass er richtig
treffe carlito nicht etwa an der arbeit
nein er ist vor der deutschstunde in
seine garage geflüchtet und hier widmet
er sich seinen wirklichen träumen und
bastelt sich seine zukunft zusammen
liegt weit weg um schattigen tschechen
ich bin ja ein garten in der
unterrichtung da wir die kirche die
weltkirche und nach einem team mit kann
häufig zu melden
so
wird es dieses jahr ausbauen
der aus wo selbst zu fragen ist es so
dass wir eigentlich
das werde umgesetzt ich finde das muss
noch zum beispiel chance darauf machen
plötzlich gas
dort wirst du leben ja ich meine zukunft
der
liter das ist offensichtlich richtet
sich an familien zwischen zwei welten
zwischen hier wo es arbeit gibt und dort
wo die seele zu hause ist
und so sind wir denn ein weiteres mal
auf dem flughafen kloten marina wartet
[Musik]
sami k leto und seine freundin tanja
waren in der karibik in den ferien wo
bringen jetzt den letzten der brüder
pepe nicht und die schweiz
[Musik]
können
jetzt sind sie alle da nur ein jahr nach
dem tod von karl marina gallito rapper
samy und freddy sie richten sich eine
existenz in der schweiz doch
wahrscheinlich wird sich ihr leben noch
lange zwischen diesen beiden welten
abspielen zu denen sie gehören haub
angekommen irgendwie noch dort aber doch
schon hier
altdorf vier jahre später zeit um die
feier abends wieder zu besuchen ich
treffe sie an einem überraschenden ort
im fitnesscenter good life wo zumindest
freddy pokallos regelmäßig trainieren
die feierabend söhne irgendwie sind sie
immer noch unterwegs zwischen diesen
beiden welten zu denen sie gehören
jedes komplett sein es soll es alles
alles bequem ein beispiel des hauses
entstehen und so sein aber
dort auf jeden fall ist unsere heimat
das kann man nichts ändern
sie leben jetzt in altdorf und erfüllen
die hiesigen normen durchaus in der
schlosserei steine hat pepe eine anlehre
gemacht erzielte mit der note 5,5 das
beste abschluss resultat im ganzen
kanton und macht jetzt noch eine
wichtige lehre sein vater wäre stolz auf
ihn und
carlos der romantiker unter den brüdern
lebt in einer neuen beziehung er ist
gerade bei seiner freundin manuela
eingezogen er versucht wir ein leben
zwischen den kontinenten schmackhaft zu
machen
die mutter marina die hier im hotel
höflich gearbeitet hatte ist nicht mehr
da sie tat sich schwer mit der sprache
dem geld dem klima
als empfehlungsdienst anfahrt zum uns
daran gewöhnen die kälte und klima die
einfach schweizer mut vermute sie ist
hält das ist einfach schwierig war es
mehr die soziale kälte oder die
klimatische kälte die deine mutter
ich denke mir die sozial kennt ja das
war mir ich denke gegen die kälte so
winter so war nicht so ein problem für
das kann man nicht kaufen
er ist einfach die leute
da hat man zum beispiel man hat kein
nachbar der karibik kommen soll nachbar
gehen
das trinken sie sind einfach ganz anders
habe er da sieht man den nachbarn
vielleicht einmal im monat oder
plötzlich wasser zu fällen sie waren
einst auch mit diesem 7 ja da ist ja
die firma ruag abteilung recycling
schattdorf hier wo viele sein ende
findet dreschen wie samuel den jüngsten
der brüder wieder
mit dem tränen vom zivilisationsmüll
verdient der knapp über 3000 franken
netto pro monat
damit hat er sich ganz gut eingerichtet
denn er der schon immer etwas anders war
machte auch jetzt alles anders als seine
brüder er lebt alleine und er hat einen
kleinen hausteil gemietet mitten in
outdoor jetzt will es allen zeigen
all jenen die ihn für zu unbegabt
hielten um im leben wirklich verfolgt zu
haben
er ist stolz auf sein kleines reich
eine adrette zweizimmerwohnung für rund
600 franken pro monat
doch seien wirkliche triumph lebt in der
karibik heißt deira und baut zur
hochzeit sein
[Musik]
mauren der schule
zusammen und was will in der schweiz tun
ich wähle sie hier eine lehre machen
und dann
zusammenarbeit und dann ein haus in
amerikanischen republik machen
so ist der letzte irgendwie der erste
zumindest was das heiraten betrifft auch
in der freizeit geht es einen eigenen
weg er ist der fitness er hat seinen
eigenen fitness club sozusagen und nun
das nächste kapitel dieser geschichte
karibische heirat
[Musik]
kleider probe da die braut ist zarte 17
jahre hat seit zwei jahren sind sie und
samuel ein paar
hier hat sie begonnen diese
liebesgeschichte im lyzeum von grunge
arriba wo die braut auch heute noch zur
schule geht
bist du in der schweiz leben mit dir
[Musik]
ich hoffe möglichst bald und was wirst
du thun in der schweiz
ich möchte etwas arbeiten zb als
verkäuferin und chemie so helfen geld zu
verdienen
[Musik]
und später möchten wir dann ein haus
bauen in der karibik und zusammen eine
familie gründen
und bald treffen wir auch marina wieder
die 50 jährige ist wieder glücklich und
sie lebt in rancho lieber auf der
gleichen finger wie damals mit calli
wie gefällt es dir denn wieder hier zu
sein
ich bin immer auf einer finca und schaue
hierzu allem zur landwirtschaft zum
garten
einen großen unterschied zur schweiz
in der schweiz war es doch immer nur
arbeit und arbeit und keine möglichkeit
selber etwas anzupflanzen
hier haben wir doch einfach alles was
wir brauchen
zusammen mit ihrem freund manolo führt
marina den hof weiter ganz im geiste des
verstorbenen karl man alle um marina
leben aus klein bauen
sie haben hühner und kühe pflanzen café
mandarinen und bananen sie sind
eigentlich selbst versorgen erdverbunden
wir leben hier nicht in einer
fantasiewelt wir führen ein richtiges
leben
ist denn auch das soziale leben in der
schweiz
aber klar wir leben hier mit den
geschwistern den eltern und den freunden
kurz vor weihnachten bescherung auf der
finca
zwei weitere söhne marinas sind
eingetroffen friedrich und sein bruder
und mit ihnen eine niegelnagelneue
waschmaschine sowie ein kühlschrank
einer der schweiz
bist du stolz auf deine söhne
klar bin ich stolz auf sie und sie auf
mich hoffe ich doch
[Musik]
zu besuch bei seinen schwiegereltern
er gefällt der bräutigam mit schweizer
pass und
sagt du bist du zufrieden mit uns
ich weiß dass du ein guter mann für sie
bist ich kannte deinen vater und deine
mutter du kommst aus einer guten familie
[Musik]
und sie da meine tochter habe ich so
erzogen dass sie fleißig ist und eine
gute hausfrau geben wird
[Musik]
die bänder
marina was hältst du dich von dieser
hochzeit
naja
sollen sie doch heiraten wenn es sein
muss
sind sie den zu jünger
er ist doch noch ein baby
ach was beide sind noch
[Musik]
da
ist immer von meister
[Musik]
im standesamt zurück auf die kleine
finca dem dreh und angelpunkt dieser
geschichte
samuel hat sich durchgesetzt
[Musik]
samuel die man so gar nichts zutraute
samuel der letzte von caris söhnen der
nun irgendwie ihr erster ist
[Musik]
ein leben zwischen zwei welten und hier
nach dort von dort nach hirt und zurück
noch lange nicht feiern
[Musik]
st